hi I am Juliana
Miss Great Germany zweitausendundsiebzehn
and I would like to be very brief
comment on the debate about the current Miss Germany 2.024.
I would like to explain 2 things to you briefly.
on the one hand how it is with the
Concept of the current bestirmen that relates to 2.024
and as compared to
international miselections takes place.
and there will be 1 2nd video where I go into it,
that old values and traditions
nowadays
blindly be abolished and thereby 1 new
Shaming developed.
I would like to tell you first very briefly My title
Explain Miss Grand Germany 2.017
and that means that,
that I 2.017 Germany
in the third largest miselection in the world
the Miss Grand
international election in Vietnam.
in the case of misses,
the situation is similar to boxing.
in boxing there are
different associations as you probably know W.
B.
A and W. B.
O.
and each federation shortens its own world champion
and that's how it is with miselections.
there are
Various elections
that shorten their own winners.
the biggest pageant in the world is the Miss Universe pageant,
you all know the second biggest choice the Miss World,
the third size the Miss Grand international,
then there is Miss international,
Miss Earth various elections and
every choice has its
own representative uh her own representative,
who represents their country in this election
and I did that in 2.017.
there I have Germany
represented at the Miss Grand International election.
before I go into it,
that I do not look German,
which I do very much.
often under the comments of the new Miss
Germany 2.024 have read,
I would like to give you a brief overview of the
Explain Miss Germany 2.024.
and that is,
this,
the organization has,
that stands behind it,
Miss Germany Studios they call themselves now I think
um,
changed the concept a few years ago.
and that is it no longer works
around the look of the winner,
but about what the woman presents,
thus represents what it is committed to.
for a good cause,
so to speak.
so each of the girls has their own mission
and they present them there.
and it shall be given a stage to this woman,
to advocate for it.
the Miss Germany
Studios so send the current
Miss Germany 2,024 on
not an international choice.
it will Germany
neither at the Miss World
still at the Miss
Universe or represent something else.
and now I want you very briefly
From my experience
report on international failures.
because it has been like this there for decades,
that it's not just about it,
that the missing have 1 respectable appearance,
but it always has 1 purpose behind it,
always a mission.
not for nothing is the slogan of Miss World
Beauty with the proposed
or the Miss Grand International Stop Siwan Violence.
so at
international elections have been the case for decades,
that the stage is used for this,
To work for a good cause,
for equality,
for frauengleichstellung,
for peace.
but
of course it is also with
international elections to this day,
that the optics,
that the outside also counts.
so.
1 total package is searched
and what I mean by total package,
that this pageant I was at,
Miss Great International
took place for 5 weeks in Vietnam.
what must a miselection 5 weeks go for,
when it's all about optics?
after 2 days you know
Who you find the most beautiful and the winner
could cool.
but that's not the point alone.
it was about finding out which mission
represents the woman,
what she stands up for and makes strong
and it also went
to find out what their personality is like,
how forgiven,
so how does she act in interviews,
how does it deal with the organization,
how does she get along with the other candidates,
who are competitors in the sense,
how does she present herself to the bus driver,
to the waiter and to the woman who cleans her room.
so we were for 5 weeks
observed and it was analyzed
to find out which woman
virtually everything combined.
Beauty
is in the view of the viewer,
but ne um
Personality she has,
1 good heart she is,
she is good-natured,
warm,
this is extremely important that I think
hardly anyone knows that,
That how important this is in elections of misunderstandings
and also what they are 1st for.
so and now some of you will think,
what is she talking about?
she is not the most beautiful herself
and people I know that,
that is also all with it I find totally fine
and I know that many of you think so,
yes why has it.
actually represented in Germany.
She doesn't look German at all.
and I know,
that I for this statement now certainly a lot of Hate
will get,
but Germany true
is and probably always will
1 racist country to remain.
I'm sorry,
unfortunately,
you can't talk about that nicely.
i have this during my
Experienced time as Miss Gwen Germany yourself,
because I have brown eyes and brown hair
and 1 slightly browner TAR.
that people thought,
yes why is Germany representing,
She's not from Germany at all,
does not look German at all.
but guys,
I come from Germany,
i was born in germany,
my parents come from Germany,
were born in Germany,
my come from Germany,
My great-grandfather is from Latin America.
yes so I am 1/8
1, 16.
is only one side Latina
and thank God I am happy,
that the genes have prevailed and I um yes
brown hair,
brown eyes have and in summer
super fast crisp brown,
when I lie down in the sun.
so i am happy about it,
but so I do not have this
typical german exterior,
where you think,
what is the typical german exterior?
blonde hair and blue eyes
is actually not typical German.
comes.
so almost all who look like this
have mostly
somewhere with their ancestor Scandinavian word sense,
but it also does not matter.
that's not about me at all.
I don't want to get out of that at all.
what I want to get out of is than I.
was chosen at the Miss Grand International,
I met such great women,
really women,
that drive me so insane
have inspired and the experience
I take with me until today.
this was one of the best for me
Experiences of my life
and because I am just so great
personalities.
still briefly what in the background the Miss Grand
was international.
the winner moves to Thailand for 1 year and will
together with the organization
travel to different countries in order to get to know different
Missions to go.
for example
to support women's rights,
to help postwar victims,
donate together in
Organize and manage Charity Galas
and she also meets ministers there,
Ambassadors and anything else.
that means that is 1 real job quasi,
who is sought with this mis-selection and
is to be executed.
and for that this woman also needs intellect,
it must be able to well,
it must be formed,
she must speak different languages,
as I just said,
the overall package must interfere,
the optics then still plays a role.
when this woman enters the stage
and her aura
and their whole appearance is first 1 Eyecatcher,
you think at first,
then she starts talking,
is also still formed and has intellect.
you think again
and then she also represents a good thing
and you just think to yourself,
yes you may not believe it,
but these women really move something.
please sit down with the
international winners of
international elections um apart,
huh?
who have already done everything in their lives
after that and around now again on the total package
to come back,
I find at this year's Miss Germany election
there was 1st girl who really
had the overall package,
which is beautiful,
which is um smart,
studied and also not fallen on the mouth,
that can,
the white
what she represents and has a certain point of view
and also just
for a good thing.
and any other country in the world would have said,
mega perfect,
we have found the best representative,
everything fits,
everything is right
and in my eyes it was Larissa.
so and now I tell you 1.
I have seen them
and I followed the 1st bit,
of course because I'm interested too,
Out of private interest
and I knew,
i knew,
That Larissa will not win because she is too beautiful
and the people,
that is so sick and that is so typical german
and that makes me so sad
and there I will now in my 2.
Go into video again.